moi je pense que ce projet de loi il
pose deux questions la première c'est
qu'elle est l'utilisation que l'on fait
de l'argent public puisque ça n'est pas
notre argent que nous gérons mais
l'argent public que ce soit sur
l'indemnité des frais de mandat que ce
soit sur l' enveloppe des collaborateurs
que ce soit sur la réserve parlementaire
par exemple et ensuite est-ce que les
décisions que l'on prend elles sont
motivées par des décisions et des
jugements politiques ou est-ce qu'on est
soumis à des intérêts particuliers et
c'est la prévention des conflits
d'intérêts c'est ça mon avis les deux
questions essentielles qu'on doit se
poser donc oui sur la réserve
parlementaire
c'était un instrument politique qu'il
faut pas se cacher la face là dessus
c'était un instrument de politique qui
permettait d'avoir une influence d'avoir
un poids politique dans sa
circonscription
oui ça a pu aider d'aider des
associations et des collectivités
locales
sauf que pour moi ça n'est pas aux
parlementaires de décider seul de
manière discrétionnaire qui est éligible
et qu'ils aient faim alors qu'elle
servait comme ce trésor écoutez moi je
pense que c'est une bonne chose qu'elle
soit supprimée à nous en tant que
parlementaire d'accompagner les
associations d'accompagner les
collectivités locales dans la rue faire
que ça va changer beaucoup de chance
pour lui à nous de les accompagnant la
recherche de subventions par exemple à
nous les a coupés dans le montage de
projets ça on peut le faire mais est ce
que c'est un député seuls de décider de
l'utilisation ou non de 150000 euros par
an de dire quelle association est
éligible ou non alors oui elle la liste
des associations que vous soutenez lé
public
mais sur quels critères vous avez fondé
votre jugement lui aura forcément est
toujours une suspicion qui pourraient
exister moi sur ma circonscription j'ai
cinquante et une commune
comment je fais l'arbitrage entre
différentes communes qui peuvent avoir
des problématiques identiques jean
priori une sur l'autre mais sur quels
critères objectifs tout 20 forcément ma
décision elle sera soumise à un
interrogatoire